veamos si podemos encontrar la
representación en serie de mclaren para
fx donde fx es igual a x cúbica que
multiplica a coseno de x cuadrada te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta recuerda
la serie mac loring no es más que la
serie de pelos centrada en x igual a 0 y
digamos que queremos encontrar los
primeros 5 términos distintos de cero de
la aproximación de mack loring de esta
función
supongo que ya lo intentaste y muy
probablemente te frustras te en el
intento pues al intentarlo te diste
cuenta que para encontrar la serie the
tail o la serie mac loring hay que
derivar esta función y esto puede ser
muy doloroso veamos
efe prima de x es igual por la regla el
producto es 3x cuadrada que multiplica a
coseno de x cuadrada más x cúbica por la
derivada de coseno de x cuadrada que es
2x por la diva de coseno que es menos
seno de x cuadrada bien esto ya fue
doloroso y se va a tornar aún más
doloroso al tomar la segunda tercera
derivada y podría ser más de 5 pues
recuerda que queremos los primeros 5
términos distintos de cero así es que la
segunda derivada va a ser dolorosa
dolorosa y la tercera y la cuarta
derivada van a ser aún más dolorosas y
entonces qué hacemos podrías hacer esto
evaluar cada uno de estos en ceros y
usarlos como coeficientes pero como
seguro ya te lo imaginaste hay una
manera más fácil de hacerlo
y te voy a dar una pista ya sabemos ya
conocemos cómo es la serie de mclaren
para coseno de x la desarrollamos en un
vídeo previo si te interesa puedes
buscarlo en khan academy se llama serie
de taylor para la función coseno en cero
ahí se describe con detalle esta que es
una de las más famosas series de mack
loring entonces sabemos que digamos que
las funciones de x la cual es igual a
coseno dx coseno de x sabemos cómo es el
desarrollo en serie de potencias para
esta función la aproximación de mclaren
para esta función esto es
aproximadamente igual a 1 - x cuadrada
sobre 2 factorial más x a la cuarta
sobre 4 factorial menos x a la sexta
sobre 6 factorial y aquí ya creo que te
das cuenta de cómo es el patrón de esta
serie el siguiente término es x
octava sobre 8 factorial y así menos más
así seguiríamos sucesivamente y aquí
tenemos los 5 primeros términos que
necesitamos aunque en realidad
necesitamos los 5 primeros términos de
esta función tenemos que ver cómo
relacionarlos con estos pero ahora que
ya hemos recordado cómo es la serie de
mack loring para coseno de x la ayuda
que te doy es cómo puedes usar la serie
de mac cloning para coseno de x para
obtener la representación en serie de la
función que nos están preguntando además
observa qué es lo que tienes aquí x
cúbica que multiplica a y aquí te estoy
prácticamente releyendo la función x
cúbica que multiplica a g de x cuadrada
con eso que te he dicho ya tienes muy
buenas pistas ahora te invito a que le
pongas pausa al vídeo y veas si lo puede
resolver por tu cuenta bien supongo que
ya lo intentaste ahora voy a escribir
acá lo que te mencioné tenemos que fx fx
es igual si la quiero escribir usando
gdx
si la quiero escribir en términos de la
función g f x es igual a x al cubo por
coseno de x cuadrada que es de x
cuadrada así es que es x al cubo x
d
x cuadrada gx cuadrada gx escocés de x
gx cuadrada es coseno de x cuadrada que
está multiplicando a x cúbica ahora hay
alguna manera de aplicar en esto que
tenemos aquí la aproximación que ya
desarrollamos para coseno de x pues sí
efectivamente si podemos hacer eso
observa que si desarrollamos esta serie
para x cuadrada en vez de x ponemos x
cuadrada vamos a tener un polinomio en x
y cuando multiplicamos por x cúbica
vamos a obtener otro polinomio que va a
ser efectivamente la representación en
serie de mack loring de la función
original fx que tenemos aquí
así es que
fx
aproximadamente igual a x cúbica que
multiplica a déjame poner suficiente
espacio aquí que multiplica gdx cuadrada
aquí tenemos la aproximación de g de x y
si desarrollamos los términos de manera
indefinida vamos a aproximarnos cada vez
más saco seno de x así es que donde haya
x vamos a sustituir x cuadrada esto es
igual a 1 - x cuadrada elevado al
cuadrado es x a la cuarta sobre 2
factorial es 2 pero lo pongo como 2
factorial para que veamos cómo es el
patrón más x cuadrada elevado a la
cuarta que es x a la octava sobre 4
factorial
- x cuadrada elevado a la sexta que es x
elevado a la 12 sobre 6 factorial + x al
cuadrado elevado a la octava que es x a
la 16 sobre 8 factorial y así
sucesivamente alternando signos aunque a
nosotros sólo nos interesan los primeros
5 términos distintos de cero de
cualquier manera hemos establecido que
esto es una aproximación así es que esto
es aproximadamente igual voy a
distribuir el producto de x cúbica y
luego ya sea en magenta para que se vea
más bonito así es que esto es
aproximadamente igual a x al cubo menos
x a la séptima sobre 2 factorial más x
elevado a la 11 sobre 4 factorial menos
equis elevado a la 15 sobre 6 factorial
más x elevado a la 19 316 19 x a la 19
sobre 8 factorial estos son los primeros
5 términos y básicamente hemos concluido
albert
te puedes dar cuenta que tuviera tomado
años hacerlo por digámoslo así fuerza
bruta porque hubieras tenido que llegar
al término x a la 19 a partir de las
primeras 4 derivadas
sin embargo cuando te das cuenta de que
puedes expresar esta función con el
producto de x cúbica y la expansión de
mack loring de coseno de x cuadrada
entonces la cosa cambia esto lo
podríamos escribir de manera general
como sigue voy a tratar de escribirlo de
tal manera que te resulte claro si puede
escribir la función como una x elevada a
una potencia n aquí podríamos incluir
una constante a que multiplica a x a la
n iv esto que multiplica a otra función
deja de ponerlo en otro color en púrpura
que multiplica a
d
ve que multiplica x elevada a otra
potencia donde yo puedo desarrollar esto
fácilmente en series si conozco la serie
mac loring deje de x si conozco lo que
es gd x entonces hago lo que hemos hecho
en este vídeo si conozco la sedema
chlorine paraje de x entonces donde
encuentre x lo voy a reemplazar por esto
que tenemos aquí b por x elevado a la
potencia m eso me va a dar otro
polinomio otra serie de potencias la
cual voy a multiplicar por x elevado a
la n iv esto me va a dar otro polinomio
la serie de potencias de mi función
original esto es realmente interesante